[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the bullet train cast is having a dance
party and
we'd like a ticket to ride
yep that's brad pitt and his bullet
train castmates at their paris premiere
getting their boogie on on the red
[Applause]
carpet the film's producer kelly
mccormick starts off with some funky
disco moves walking with director david
leach and the cast they brought that
same good energy
[Music]
brian tyree henry busts a move with
aaron taylor johnson seems pretty clear
these two are close buds
joey king also gets in on the fun
literally during brian's interview and
brad he was a playful goofball all night
no seriously when we say all night we
mean all night
[Music]
[Applause]
the oscar winner put those silly moves
into words explaining why he was in such
a great mood
it feels really good to
put something in the theaters you know
the people who come together and laugh
just get silly and forget about
everything else for a minute but wait
the fun doesn't stop on the red carpet
brian is joey's biggest hype man
cheering for her as she enters the
theater for the film screening and brad
showed aaron that same love which again
brings us back to more dancing
[Applause]
and the love fest continues on stage the
actors don't waste any time opening up
about their special bond oh man i don't
want to spoil it for you man but i love
this guy we have a lot of love and a lot
of care i care
[Music]
and for brad the guy's just truly stoked
to be out living his best life can't say
we blame him it was just in the middle
of lockdown you know that that point
where we were all getting a little crazy
a little cuckoo a little dark a little
depressed and it came the script
with great characters
funniest [ __ ] and it just seemed like
the perfect sad for this time and it's
so great to be here now
to be here in paris to like let out the
summer we're all here together and it's
just it's really great
brad please never stop dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
you